okay so what are a couple books on
marketing and media that you'd recommend
the advertising man if you will be yes
it's the old one yeah anything with
Kellogg there's another one called the
positioning contagious as a must it's an
orange book then I did a whole video
when I said the top 10 to read on
marketing the thing about marketing is
people think sales and marketing is the
same thing sales is here's the options
let me find out what your pressure
points are let me get the objections I
know the FAQs we're getting to a point
which one do you want to go do you see
any reason why we shouldn't get started
today no we do marketing is storytelling
knowing who not to compete with you know
who's going to be a waste of time that
you're gonna lose that battle look at
Jake Paul Jake Paul fought two UFC
fighters where did Jake Paul fight him
did he fight him in UFC Rules or boxing
rules boxing why did he fight them in
boxing rules what would have happened if
Jake Paul fought Ben Astron in UFC Rules
who do you think it's game over so
marketing is you getting your story to
be in an area that you have an advantage
now your competitor